بملامح مشابهه حد التطابق استطاع شعبيه
اللاعب البرازيلي نيمار خداع المسؤولين
والسلطات المختصه في مونديال قطر
ليدخل كانه النجم العالمي لسات 974 متجولا
في ارضيه الملعب الذي شهد مباراه البرازيل
وسويسرا الشاب المخادع لم يكن الا احد
المؤثرين البرازيليين على تطبيق تيك توك
ويدعى ايجن اوليفيرا ويتبعها اكثر من نصف
مليون شخص نظر التشابه الكبير بينه وبين
اللاعب البرازيلي اظهر مقطع فيديو مؤثر
البرازيلي وهو يدخل للارضيات استاذ متجلا
فيها ومحاطا في عدد من المسؤولين الملعب
قبل ان يتوجه الى مدرجات
ليبدا الجمهور بتسابق عليه لالتقاط صوره
سيلفي مع النجم البرازيلي قبل ان يكتشف ان
الذي يتصور معه لم يكن الا مخادعا
[موسيقى]